dimanche non annoncées pour être le
rendez-vous que j'obtienne un petit peu
de temps au 7e match up s'est passé le
dixième au 7e 13e ma gueule entendu 10e
c'est plus ponte durée une mais qui
sous-estiment mon job
un matin cgt à chaque fois aussi oh
ouais mais ça c'était avant mon frère là
c'est universal music c'est pas pareil
t'inquiète pas lé plus grand signe
là-bas elvis prins michael mimie mathy
est au pain vivaldi tout le monde en
avait qui rigole mais c'est vrai que
l'histoire un coût mais d'ailleurs c'est
quoi pense à mon argent parce que je
serai votre manager officiel tu verras
ouais c'est pas toi qui étreint et qui
fait les alertes au strasbourg paris
pour rien mais tu m'écoutes pas en fait
je m'écoute pas j'ai dit que tout ça
c'est terminé basta si carmelo tu
prépares mais tu parce que bientôt je
serai ton agent dont l'assistant du
manager dont l'assistant manager du
styliste ckoi et même ton coiffeur
mais quoi au c'est ça l'esprit de
famille mon frère là c'est le combat qui
aiment cette fondation et c'est le 13e
13 rendez vous dans le vent comme d'hab'
tu fait tourner en rond depuis des
années en fait avec des plans demi tour
parisienne merle samarrai universal de
disques tout grand homme de ce que tout
va changer tout va changer
le gâteau mais nous parlerons on dirait
on est venu nous demander du temps pour
nettoyer dans leurs bureaux